This used to be a mangrove forest.
It is absolutely decimated.
This is what climate change looks like.
The mangroves died along 2,000 kilometers of shoreline...
...in the Gulf of Carpentaria.
There was 76 square kilometers, that's  7,600 hectares of mangroves, were killed.
These studies have identified what killed them was a drop in sea level...
...that occurred with a very severe El Nino at the time.
We've known about the drops in sea level correlated with El Nino,...
...but strangely enough, these impacts,...
...even though, as big as they are on mangroves,...
...they haven't been noticed or recognized before.
The dieback was caused by a lack of moisture.
Yeah.
So what we need to do is find a way to water these plants on scale,...
...aerial watering or even watering from ships.
There's five or six times more carbon in mangrove forests than most other forests.
We can just keep these trees alive and the habitat intact.
Then we can preserve these benefits.